as the diplomacy seemingly gets nowhere
many here are putting their faith in a
higher power and are praying for peace
at this service in the capital they also
called for unity they know this crisis
is moving into dangerous territory
outside the cathedral there is a wall of
remembrance
more than thirteen thousand people have
lost their lives since the conflict
erupted in 2014 when russia occupied
crimea
these women are making camouflage nets
in their spare time to center the front
they know it's not much but they want to
volunteer
maybe i'm a little bit worried but i try
to keep calm and prepare
we
hope for the best but
of course we
we must be prepared for the
wars and all the time the build-up
continues
western intelligence agencies claim
russia could attack at any moment
moscow maintains these are just military
drills
there is no doubt nerves are becoming
more jittery as time goes by with
questions now
about whether ukraine's airspace will
remain open to commercial flights it is
for the moment
but the warnings of an imminent invasion
have once again been played down by the
government here it even criticized its
u.s ally for sowing panic
and failing to provide any evidence
but many countries are spooked warning
their citizens to leave this was the
picture in the russian-backed separatist
city of donetsk the organization for
security and cooperation evacuating u.s
staff from its mission
i spoke by phone last night with russian
foreign minister lavrov
where i raised our serious concerns that
moscow may be considering launching a
military attack against ukraine in the
coming days i also underscored that if
moscow chooses the path of aggression
and further invades ukraine the response
in the united states and our allies will
be swift
it will be united
it will be severe
the kremlin though is accusing the west
of hysteria and misinformation
this delivery of stinger missiles from
lithuania will be viewed as a further
provocation
but ordinary ukrainians are worried
at this shooting range men who could end
up being part of a civilian resistance a
training in the basics of warfare
now when we face
this uh
complicated situation on our borders and
we don't know about the future steps of
our neighbor we have to be ready
to act somehow it is hard though to be
ready when you don't know what's going
to happen people are doing their best to
get on with their lives as normal but
all the time are wondering where this
crisis is heading alex rossi sky news
kiev